hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb bimby and today I wanted
to go over a classic chess game from
history and that is a chess game from
Vera men chick who is actually the first
woman's world champion
Judit Polgar is probably a name most
chess players are familiar with in the
history of women's chess and especially
women breaking through into that really
top top level of chess competing with
the top players in the world of any
gender Judah of course was in the top
ten and was was one of the greatest
female players of all time
the name less familiar is this very mint
chip name and she actually was also
competing with some of the best chess
players at the time including max Oliva
who became a world champion later on and
so today I want to take a look at one of
her games against max and see what she
managed to accomplish against the future
world champion future at the time so
let's see what the game started with
here it was d4 d5 c4 c6 Knight f3 Knight
f6 Knight c3 D takes c4 we have a Slav
where black goes ahead and takes on c4
of course white wants to regain this
pawn so she plays a for preventing this
move b5 black takes the time to develop
his Bishop out to f5 now we see III
regaining this pawn without too much
controversy controversy here black plays
Knight a6 white captures on c4 and now
after night before black is making this
a slightly strange maneuver to try and
put some pressure on these light squares
for white that looked just a little bit
Airy white is not afraid of this though
and simply castles knights e2 doesn't
really achieve anything here in fact II
for might be a winning tactic for for
the white player so instead of Knight
see to simply 6 and perhaps the true
purpose of this Knight is to help
control this d5 square rather than go in
for these lights cortex
95 is why it's choice now black
continues with Bishop d6 and now we see
Queen e2 a very common move in the Slav
just preparing this break with E for
supporting the pawns from behind and
also allowing this rook the very nice d1
square and now black plays a very silly
move which is c5 it's simply a little
bit too early to go in for this kind of
pawn break because the moves c5 is
actually giving up too much light square
control on this diagonal in particular
Vera actually plays this move Bishop b5
checking the King and there's no
comfortable way to respond to this check
you of course can't play knight c6 this
night will be captured and the king and
rook will be Forks you don't have enough
coverage over the d7 square white will
simply capture there as well and so you
must move the King here in fact King f8
is the best that black can do but now
white can respond very naturally with
the movie for taking more space in the
center in fact in the game max actually
played a worse move King e7 and this
move is is far far too ambitious
the idea of King g7 is probably that
black wanted to get this rook out of the
way before bringing the King to f8 but
you simply don't have time white plays
very actively still playing this break
efore in the center black must retreat
the bishop and now white snaps this
bishop off the board with 9 takes g6 in
h6 GH takes g6 and now after E 5 white
is simply tactically already winning a
piece she has simply outplayed max from
the opening and she doesn't let up from
there weather continues with C takes d4
white brings this rook to d1 not
immediately capturing either of these
pieces and there are some fun tactics
here as well for example if you think
you can take this Knight you're a little
bit wrong rook takes d6 comes on the
board and after the Queen moves white
can play pawn takes f6 not caring about
this rook because you develop with tempo
Bishop f4 check and after King's c5
check
me is incoming for this king so Rick do
you want a very nice move keeping as
much pressure as possible bringing more
pieces into the attack
Bishop c7 tries to save the bishop but
now white simply captures this night and
after takes note that black has made a
threat to the aged pawn so white takes
the time to defend it simply g3 and of
course this pin still exists on this
pawn a6 was what black tried to try and
remove this piece from it's very active
square on b5 but here Vera actually just
totally ignores this threat
instead playing Bishop e3 the idea being
if black wants to regain his piece he
has to allow something like Bishop takes
d4 when after move like Bishop c5 you're
going to be losing this piece losing
your queen losing all sorts of things
and in fact Bishop d6 simply doesn't
really help you can imagine Queen f3 and
after E 5 Bishop c5 can come on the
board anyways with this Bishop all
pinned up in all sorts of ways so you
cannot take this Bishop on b5 instead
Mac's defenses pawn on d4 but now after
a simple Bishop c4 black is starting to
find safety for his King but the safety
is not enough as White has already won a
full piece in this position we see Rick
h5 this Fischer comes out to f4 now and
E 5 solidifies the pawn chain just a bit
but now g4 for white creates a very nice
little outpost for her Bishop here on g3
queen e7 to follow and now she plays
Knight d2 rerouting this Knight just a
bit brick he8 we see this Queen come to
e4 very choosing instead to get the
knight of the way so the Queen can be
the more active peace Queen d7 Knight m3
Queen c6 max actually realizes that he's
going to be coming under a little bit
too much pressure
after this move g5 so he takes this time
to offer a queen trade and Vera actually
obliges here
just going into an endgame up a piece
again continued with Bishop d5 rook c8
Bishop back to e4 max now tries to make
use of this C file but it's simply not
enough this Knight comes back to an ice
block hitting square on d3 also
supporting the c1 square for the rooks
97 we see a couple more trades come on
the board
King f1 rook c4 and now after Bishop e7
okay for it's white with control of the
C file black plays g5 simply f3 the
extra piece is all you really need to
know here the bishop comes back to e1
very activating all of her pieces in
this endgame Bishop d2 and now black
tries to break free with f5 but it's
simply just not working G takes f 5 a4
from black and now simply king e1 not
even taking any of these garbage pawns
she'll collect them later a3 is blacks
choice trying to make use of the second
rank simply be for from white is good
enough we see King f6 and now Bishop a6
is a very very nasty move simply
bringing this bishop over to the c-4
square where it is finally realized that
this rook is totally trapped by its own
pawn on a3 so takes takes and now the
end of the game is very very near with
Vera up an entire rook here the game did
continue for some more moves though we
see Bishop d8 this should be 6 check
King back to f6 Bishop g4 hitting this
pawn Knight d5 she collects this pawn
Knight takes b4 simply Bishop a4 and
after Bishop e7 9390 to rook c6 check
King g5 rook g6 check if I can play it
king age 4 now after 95 Knight c3 king
d3 max went ahead and and resigned in
this position so a very nice game from
Mara she was winning from the opening
she kept up the pressure she kept up
some very active pieces using some very
nice tactics
managed to win this game against world
champion maxilla and I wanted to show
this game because I think Vera deserves
a lot more Fame a lot more popularity
than she currently has she's one of the
all-time greats in the game of chess and
she was kind of Judit Polgar almost a
hundred years before Judit Polgar it was
was playing chess and so be sure to
check out more of her games be sure to
read up more about her she is in the
world chess Hall of Fame there's a very
nice entry about her that I would
recommend checking out but for the
moment that's all for me thank you so
much for joining me on this episode of
doing review my name is Caleb Denby and
I will see you in the next episode